e aí galera que supervisiona tudo vocês
só eu tô bem pra [ __ ] e sabe porquê
porque o nosso canal ele completou oito
feitos mil e que a meta é igual agora 1
milhão chega não sabe se vai fazer você
vai agora o twitter você vai colocar o
vídeo que você mais gosta é meu lar com
a hashtag widerson rumo a um milhão de
inscritos é depois de acabar o verão é
agora você atue ter você vai lá o que
mais gosta é sei lá desabafa satanás
técnico joga lá e coloca nextag o eles
são um rumo a um milhão de inscritos já
que tá aqui ó a chegar na minha mesa eu
criei e ganso era obrigado mesmo a sério
e eu só tenho 19 anos ao sair de casa
com 17 anos ele ia voltar dois dias
depois que eu só ia fazer um teste para
a seleção nunca mais voltei todo mundo
sem acreditar no que dizem que não ia
dar certo e hoje eu digo mais de 30
milhões de visualizações na internet foi
o maior canal investir no youtube talvez
um dos maiores do brasil foi um dos três
sindicatos vai receber o oscar da
internet nos estados unidos não fui
porque infelizmente não vai dar
província eu perder se eu perder outro
só saber que vocês me ajudar a ganhar
isso tudo bem eu fico feliz em marcar
até a expressão mudou quando ocorre um
vídeo que o meio 5 mil pessoas cuidarem
gostei o 2005 10 mil pessoas do s 15 o
pessoal [ __ ] isso é muito bom para isso
é muito bom ter ele existem milhares
mais bonito que tem muitos canais
maiores com deus mas desenvolvimento ea
resposta de vocês quando eu coloco um
vídeo novo é muito [ __ ] vocês não podem
por vocês
então fui lá no twitter você quiser
quiser desejar parabéns
o vídeo que você mais gostou quando você
quiser colocar a hashtag cuida com 1
milhão de inscritos é nós então agora
vou começar o vídeo de uma forma legal
iml de estréia eu não sabia que você
estava na hora falei você mora sozinho
como é que você fica como é possível
verificar você faz ou comendo e falando
faz uma comida que tem gente que não
acredita que eu faço comida até hoje já
fala que ele disse mas é muito fácil
horas a uma média de hoje é querido só
que é o seguinte não sei se você sabe
mas se você comer miojo tipos incluindo
cinco anos seguidos 6 ano seguinte o
número sobe hoje você fala é morre
passei muito tempo melhore só de olho e
não te fornece a coisa funcionar todos
nossos vídeos fosse coisa para nós
sobreviver e se fosse assim não tinha pé
de manga nem pede banda nem pegar a
gente aqui pede mil estão hoje eu vou
ensinar aqui pra vocês mas vai pra fazer
o que construí cuscuz é um segmento do
nordeste pode ser um pouco estranho
excurso coisa que é onde eu moro é como
se fosse um podcast que vocês conheceram
em minas gerais é como se fosse um pão
normal que vocês comem sede em são paulo
como se fosse a capoeira que vocês
jovens e da bahia então vou ensinar
agora como é que falta fazer muita coisa
pra vocês muito fácil é negócio com as
coisas que afetam muito o bahia chega
pra mim foi feita consulta terá 1 passa
com um cabo da capital do catar doha
catar
kaká já dá pra fazer com os punhos
primeiramente você vai precisar de umas
coisas não é suficiente de plástico mais
conhecido como vasilha e tesoura sem
ponta porque deus em conta porque
tutorial passado
fazer alguma coisa e tesoura sem ponta e
eu quero que tenha tesoura sem ponta no
meu também
só isso que você acha que você é capaz
que meu canal pede que ele é ruim você
não é ninguém está realmente muito mais
comida porque não sei quantos ao coloca
tal como é que você vai aprender lotação
e comida fazia você vai fazer a primeira
vez a primeira vez em maceió
a meta só porque pela primeira vez de
viver com medo de botar muito sal a
gente volta muito culpa em curso e vai
cometer erros por diogo hora já a
segunda vez que vou fazer é se vai sair
ó pior do que a primeira porque tu vai
ver senão da primeira saiu um defunto
acho melhor botar um pouco mais a ítaca
sal na comida quanto vai comer psd falam
pelo maratonista de gás em são salvador
a terceira é sempre a primeira derrotou
saúde - na semana voltou demais na
defesa já não era monica o ano deles o
dono só voltamos ao juro está no
hospital se molha para deixar um pouco
medo não deixe água não voltará assim ó
assim ó misturou se deixe descansar um
minuto assim eu só quero ficar um pouco
quando descanso pois tem que ser fácil
vai trabalhar na panela é essa aqui é a
panela você faz uma coisa é ter uma
parte macho ou em cima tem isso aqui
você colocar de março e coloca em risco
em cima a água o feg e segue com o suíço
está em cima chegou nos cuidar sem gols
curva que não couber 15 de todos dentro
você deixa a segunda vez que não pode
amarrar a airbus ea direita no brasil 10
não pode empurrar
só que sem o fogo sendo o fogo
a cobra já ter posto fogo demora mais ou
menos assim tinha uns 8 a 10 minutos
para fazer então enquanto ele fazia um
ex mulher foi muito da galera do twitter
que não é do twitter o endereço de um
júri possa entrar perguntou por que zé
roberto deu lhes meu filho de blog mais
famoso é o em meu nome é joão é lá que
faz uma piadinha que tem um negócio de
roberto carlos você não sabe o que quer
e roberto é que você não é meu fosse
libertado pelo seu uso ainda perguntou
como ter um canal e não ligar porque as
pessoas pensam em mandar é de itajaí que
eu passo aí
desde 2008 as vendas se incomoda porque
o canal que é muito muito grande eu sou
uma pessoa muito simples motor que
normal que o uso de chinelo e tal eu
tenho um ridículo aqui do meu lado eu
faço vez flamengo vê como ridícula a
eliana pereira está perguntando ele está
apaixonado tossin uma cheia de amores no
meu coração
a briga peixoto está aberto quanto ao
sabor de sorvete preferido olha hoje
napolitano porque eu sou muito sonhadora
volte a comer tudo de uma vez por causa
da política da escolha sempre uma com o
primeiro pra comer com o primeiro
chocolate
depois eu fui básico de morango é caso
não queira eu deixo de baunilha para mim
a briga tanto está perguntando o que te
inspira a fazer tais vídeos os temas dos
vídeos temos um filho a tudo que
acontece na minha vida agora que estou
ensinando a vocês como é que faz comida
porque porque quando vim morar sozinho
tive que aprender a fazer comidas não
morrer de funk buia são barra o a cnn
está perguntando quando soube que você
usa eu não somos somente deixa o sangue
de cimento a ementa perguntando você
ainda faz música sim eu faço música só
que é só quando a inspiração vem - e não
ficar só uma célula da pele tão humano
eu sou do nordeste
você vai superar esse preconceito filho
da [ __ ] que existe entre as regiões
aonde e quando você tem que fazer é você
se eu fosse pegar porque a pessoa fala
só pessoa nordeste já tinha existido já
como nilton aqui com o canal 1 800 m3 1
a 1 milhão ea e chama amanhã é também a
júlia até então lavar roupa fez e também
pegou em mim mas nem assim a mulheres
entre elas um prato ela vai abaixo da
baixada respeitosa
se não tiver aqui já dá um like neste
curso cujo nome é lógico que você vai
comer cuscuz e neto nada então eu tô a
campanha limpa matar pra vocês
na festa que estava na cama
[Aplausos]
[Música]
essa galinha ela dá na geladeira olha
você que o argumentário nós podemos ter
também uma marca não podemos volta com
os cursos com lentidão maravilha ou
mesmo um ovo tem várias opções aí tem
mais opções a ele muito obrigado por ter
tido até aqui foi todo do instituto meu
deus quando vejo já explicara que li
shishi anne itto não eu ficar aplicado
gostei
já está entendendo que eu tô te dizer
lembrar aqui que eu não gostei você que
ajuda muita ajuda muito o canal 36
você comente aqui embaixo qual é a
comida preferida de vocês foi a primeira
que você mais gosta como tem macho quero
ver se a primeira vez a etapa nacional
sobre quem escrever e saber que você
está vendo meu canal futura e
inscrever-se toda vez que tiver de novo
você vai ver pedindo novo nilo valeu
todo mundo é pego um todo mas todo mundo
me pergunta no twitter meu twitter é
esse aqui você quiser me seguir o acordo
foi a pergunta de novo em participar
valeu nada boa a sociedade olha acontece
idec e tchau